[Music]
is he still in prison busy trying on a
new batman outfit here's a look at why
michael keaton's vulture wasn't in no
way home spider-man no way home is chock
full of villains from former spidey
films with alfred molina's doc ock
making a grand entrance by tearing apart
a highway in pursuit of tom holland
spider-man in the second act
hello peter stealing the show is willem
dafoe as norman osborne who plays nice
before delivering a devastating blow as
green goblin then there's sandman
electro and lizard one from each of the
five spider-man movies outside the
marvel cinematic universe even eddie
brock from the venom franchise pops up
in a quick post credits scene though
he's far too busy getting his mind blown
by the existence of the mcu to take any
real part in the grand scheme of no way
home things oh and as if that wasn't
enough multiverse goodness the movie
also gives fans the glorious return of
two previous big screen peter parkers
portrayed by tobey maguire and andrew
garfield hi
[Music]
how did you get out there
the fire escape
with all the returning villains many
were no doubt wondering if vulture from
spider-man homecoming would show up too
in the mcu michael keaton's vulture aka
adrian toombs is spidey's first super
villain
he cuts a menacing figure in the film
with his giant mechanical wings but is
of course foiled by spider-man in the
end we last saw him in one of the
homecoming post-credits scenes where
he's in prison talking to mack gargan
aka scorpion and is unwilling to reveal
spider-man's identity
if i knew who he
was he'd already be dead
despite the tease in that post-credit
scene vulture plays no part in no way
home here's why we think he was absent
due to peter botching doctor strange's
spell spider-man villains from other
universes are pulled into the mcu
timeline
what's happening
they're starting to come through
and i can't stop them
those who know spider-man's true
identity come through which is the
opposite effect of what the spell
intended however all members of
spider-man's rogues gallery who
prominently feature in the movie as well
as the figures you see knocking at the
proverbial door during the movie's
climax have one thing in common they're
all coming through from other universes
and the only ones who actually make it
through are characters who have already
been in different spider-man movies
defoe's green goblin molina's doc ock
and church's sandman all hail from sam
raimi's spider-man trilogy while rhys
ethan's lizard and jamie foxx's electro
both come from mark webb's the amazing
spider-man movies and hardy's venom is
his own thing the movie also seems to go
for one iconic villain per movie which
rules out baddies like james franco's
new goblin
no
he despised you
you were an embarrassment to him sure
keaton's vulture knows spider-man's
identity but since the movie's villains
are specifically from different
universes that pretty much rules mr
tombs out after all vulture is already
firmly entrenched in the marvel
cinematic universe so he doesn't really
fit the villain requirements to play a
big role in no way home besides even if
he did there's the fact that as far as
viewers know vulture is still in prison
after the events of spider-man
homecoming as spider-man no way home
readily and repeatedly proves you can
never count a good spider-man villain
out just because they've been defeated
in one movie
besides michael keaton's impending
return as batman implies that the acting
legend is still perfectly willing to
operate in the world of superheroes as
such it might very well be that one of
the reasons you didn't see keaton's
flying villain in spider-man no way home
is that he's already set to feature in
another upcoming project a recent
trailer revealed that some version of
vulture will likely be in sony's
upcoming morbius at least judging by the
fact that keaton appears as a man who
sure seems to be adrian toombs talking
to the titular dr morbius hey dr mike
you and i should stay in touch according
to the hollywood reporter keaton is
indeed playing vulture in the movie even
though it appears that morbius doesn't
take place in the mcu instead it exists
in the same universe as venom which is
certainly different from the mcu going
by the fact that the venom let there be
carnage and spider-man no way home
post-credit scene depict eddie brock
being transported between the two
universes as such it certainly seems
that you will see keaton's vulture
sooner rather than later only it's in a
different corner of the multiverse than
you might have expected
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you